جميع السلع يمتاز يمتزج احيانا فيها النفط
او في السياسه مع السلعه نفسها جميع السلع
بدون استثناء امين بما في ذلك سلعه مثل
الشاهي وكذا الثوره الامريكيه لما قام ضد
بريطانيا كان يسمونها ثوره الشاي
ولكن احنا في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بشكل خاص وفي دول اوروبا بشكل عام لاننا
نعتمد واقتصادياتنا ودخلوا شعوبنا تعتمد
البترول نسعى
دي جميع الطرق ان نجنب
السياسه او نبعد السياسه عن البترول يعني
بمعنى اخر ان تكون السياسه البتروليه
مرتبطه فقط باوضاع السوق وبالذات من ناحيه
العرض والطلب حيث هدفا الرئيسي هو توازن
السوق واستقرارها على المدى القصير
والطويل ولذلك السياسه من جانبنا بعيده عن
البترول
ولكن بعض الدول لا شك ان تدخل السياسه في